I want you to imagine any piece of
machinery that's been made to run a
certain way but you purposely start
abusing it and running it the opposite
way of what has been created or how it's
been created to run common sense
obviously is gonna dictate that
eventually it's gonna malfunction this
machinery is gonna malfunction is gonna
break down now I want you to imagine how
about the human being who's been made in
the natural way on the pure fitrah to
believe but now you start covering up
that belief forcing yourself fighting
you start doing a jihad a struggle
against the natural way that you've been
created for to believe look at the
example of this person who did just that
a person who left the natural way and is
quoted to have said I left religions and
I abandon all beliefs and put my faith
in science and scientific logic alone to
my great surprise in amazement I found
myself pay attention to what he says
here I found myself happier and more
confident then I had been when I had
struggled with myself in the attempt to
maintain my religious belief and this is
what creates a lot of confusion where
you see a person like this how can he be
happier when he left faith he left
believe he left him and he left his
connection with his creator which we
don't know if he ever had the proper
connection but how can he be happier and
more confident because we want to be
confident we want to be happier but then
what happens sometime later so now a
person gets confused and you see the
professors at the universities and their
intellectuals and you don't know what's
going on behind the scenes how this is
this is systematically set up and and
anybody comes out and speaks it's a
really great documentary called spelled
no intelligence allowed so any
he comes out arguing for creationism for
a creator and gets blacklisted so you
don't know what's going on behind the
scenes how this has been systematically
set up so you get confused but then we
see this happening we see people like
this person an individual like this who
claims to be more happier more confident
committing suicide found what a suicide
note talking about his hatred for life
but I'm happier I'm more confident in my
decision in my way now and imagine what
kind of confusion that creates in the
minds of the masses so I wanted to bring
you this example because it's very this
is very common and and it creates a lot
of confusion and that's the point of
this example
don't fall for these empty slogans we
see it all around us from the TV ads of
the drug companies commercial and
everybody's running around happiest can
be Szalai from the music videos of some
of the most miserable people painting a
picture perfect life as if they're the
happiest in that 2-3 minute video that's
another lie don't fall for it from your
friends or strangers who post some of
the most amazing beautiful pictures you
think they were the happiest people in
the world but you don't know what's in
the heart only Allah the creator of the
heavens and earth knows what's in the
hearts people are great at faking it
with their fake materialism lifestyle
showing it off while you're falling more
into depression thinking that you have
it the worst in the world forgetting to
look to those who have less and looking
at all those pictures all those posts
and people faking it throwing those
making those impressions as if they're
the happiest but again
you don't know what's going on in their
hearts don't fall for these tricks and
traps by the biggest pimp pimping the
people Shaitaan in the dark satanic
forces there are too many exec too many
examples of this people who seem to be
the happiest like this example I just
gave you but at the end are some of the
most depressed people on the planet and
the reality is when you go against this
is the reality when you go against your
true purpose in life and you cover up
this belief in your Creator the natural
way we see the more atheism we have the
data shows that the countries with the
most atheists are having the most
suicide rates and don't get fooled now
because now they even have made it legal
in many of these same countries that
assisted suicide or death this is where
people who can't take living anymore
they now get assistance in taking their
own life so again don't be fooled by
these fake slogans I'm the happiest I'm
happier than I ever was more confident
my religion is science
I don't need belief or a creator in my
life bla bla bla and then shortly later
if you stick around until the end you
see that many of them lived the most
miserable life and with a miserable end
and it doesn't my brothers and sisters
in humanity Muslims who are falling into
these traps good human beings who argued
becoming victims to many of this mass
manipulation and many of these fake
slogans and lies the materialism the
worship of money and power and status
all of these things that are out there
trying to people who are living in the
concrete jungles and they're trying to
disconnect the Creator from your life
don't it doesn't have to be this way it
doesn't have to be like that
we know truly who's the source of the
and tappman the peace the solace where
this comes from this happiness it comes
from living a life that is purposeful
not purposeless living your life
according to the purpose that your
Creator has created you to live this is
how you can be more happier more
confident have more contentment peace
and satisfaction in life you will
struggle but now living the life that
the creator's created you to live for
providing you the blueprint now you have
the tools and the mechanisms to get
through these struggles these struggles
that all of us go through in life and
I'll end with this beautiful ayah from
the verbatim word of God Almighty the
Quran where he tells us where allah god
almighty is telling us verily in the
remembrance of god do hearts find rest i
remember when i read this i in the
beginning of my journey i read this and
I had a tear come through down my face
because now that I started to implement
this Deen I started to feel what the
almighty was mentioning in his book the
Quran I felt the heart was finally at
peace it was finally at rest and this is
allah speaking alladhina amanu wa
tottemo Kalu boomba the krill be the
krill he taught my ANILCA lewb this is
where it's at this is where the
happiness the peace comes from as Allah
the Almighty is saying those who believe
and whose hearts find rest in the
remembrance of Allah in the Almighty
this is the creator of the universe the
creator of you me this is the one God
and then he continues on saying verily
and the remembrance of Allah do hearts
find rest I hope this has been a benefit
if you guys are struggling with some of
these issues
asana has a really great course on this
check them out
and I'll continue to tune in to the Dean
show see you next time peace be with you
I said I'm on a comb